I've been trying to prepare myself for this
first segment because this is some of the
things,
funniest stuff that I have ever seen of Donald
Trump went to India to hang out with Indian
prime minister Narendra Modi who actually
shares some policy ideas with Trump. Trump
doesn't want to fund dealing with climate
change. Modi cut the budget for dealing with
the environment by 50%. Modi wants to privatize
the economy on and sort of neoliberal framework
the same way that Donald Trump does many similarities
between the two liters. So Trump goes to India
and Modi speaks and then Trump speaks before
a massive crowd embarrasses himself by mispronouncing
so much stuff. And there's video of the crowd
literally fleeing the stadium, like the, the
exits are packed. It's as if the Patriots
are up 40 in the fourth quarter and the place
is clearing out to avoid traffic and the visual,
it's like a horror movie. It's like a disaster
movie where everyone is just running away
from Donald Trump's speech.
It's so embarrassing in every way. And let's
go through it. Uh, it started off really oddly
with Trump walking out into the stadium to
the tune of the village people song macho,
man, it's already weird. I'm not going to
play that segment, uh, because I don't want
to have copyright issues today. We had plenty
yesterday, which I'll tell you about later.
Uh, and check this out this now, this is very
risky stuff to put on a teleprompter in front
of Donald Trump. The name Swami Vivekananda.
That's risky. And Trump of course, refers
to him as Kevin and it's just as good as it
sounds
as the great religious teachers. Swami VVA.
C'mon none.
That's a doozy. I mean like why even put that
up on a prompter for Trump, right? It's just
a, a relentlessly a self-destructive then
Trump mangoes, the names of two Indian cricket
stars, 10 Tendo car and Coley. And this is
just so entertaining.
Where are your people share on some of the
world's greatest cricket players from Suchin
10.
No, dude told me
he also mispronounced Vedas, uh, ancient Hindu
religious texts as Vestas, which is something
else altogether. And then of course the place
by the time Trump was done speaking was half
empty or more because thousands, tens of thousands
of people were running for the exits while
Donald Trump was speaking. Trump, of course,
trying to sell it. As you know, I had a crowd
of 100,000, and it's true at the outset it
was very, very full. But the report from the
BBC is that as the speech went on and Trump
was making a fool out of himself, people started
to get up and leave. And you can see in the
video, uh, the, uh, crowd formed at the exits.
People could not exit quickly enough. And
as you can see, if you're watching the stadium
ends up half empty while Donald Trump is a,
is talking. Can you imagine the BBC reporting
quote crowds began leaving midway through
the U S president's speech a net. Let's now
check out the video with the audio and you
will see that as Donald Trump is speaking,
the exits are crammed. It's almost like a
bomb went off and everybody's trying. It's
like the place is on fire and people are trying
to get out of a crowded theater. People barely
able to squeeze out, uh, as Donald Trump is
speaking, take a look
rich and poor young at all. Take pride in
the glories of your past, unite for an even
brighter future and let our two nations always
stand together as powerful defenders of peace
and Liberty and the hope of a better world.
It's
amazing. Just one laughing stock after another.
It is truly, truly amazing stuff. And uh,
overall a very embarrassing trip for the United
States. Donald Trump being in India as is
often the case. I mean it's often the case
that when Donald Trump travels abroad, it's
very embarrassing for the United States. And
this is one of the things that, you know,
it's going to take some time. Once Trump has
gone, there will be relationships that have
to be rebuild. The, the sort of, um, I don't,
I don't even really want to call it prestige,
but the knowledge on the behalf of our, our
allies and counterparts, geopolitical counterparts,
they're not all allies. They're knowledge
that they are dealing with a real diplomat,
someone that can be trusted, someone who understands
things, that's going to take some time to
rebuild a lot of those relationships. And
the next thing I want to talk about is the
wacky press conference that Donald Trump gave
a, I guess it would be sort of this morning
India time, uh, during this trip.
Let's talk about
that next.